une boutique de la rue Victor Hugo
centre ville de Fort-de-France pas
franchement comme les autres ici on y
vend des articles issus de matières
souples de tissus récupérés comme ces
sacs c'est vrai que c'est du recyclage
mais j'ai beaucoup apprécié le concept
puisque j'en ai fait une acquisition
pour une amie et son modèle a beaucoup
plus
vraiment c'est je ne peux que
recommander pas que des sacs des sets de
table des coussins plein d'autres choses
encore qui sortent d'ici dans cette
unité de production basée au prêcheur il
s'agit de chantier et ateliers
d'insertion dirigés par l'association
Les Ateliers solidaires et créatifs à sa
tête d'anciennes couturières
associations où on évoluait entre
couturières entre artisans d'aliment
nous avons décidé de gérer un petit peu
des déchets des déchets parce que il y
avait matière à créer de l'emploi
bonjour tout le monde bonjour les chutes
de matelas super on en a besoin vraiment
en ce moment une tâche immense et l'idée
de créer un chantier d'insertion dans
une zone sinistrée du point de vue
économique en août 2020 naissent les
artisans du recyclage plus de 2 ans
après la structure tourne à pleurer
régime vêtements usé déchets de la
profession et même des chutes de
production et industrielles affluent sur
le site alors tu choisis les épaisseurs
qui sont comme celles parce que sont ces
pièces là qu'on veut reproduire d'accord
et donc tu vas avoir les dimensions ça
doit être tu vois un petit peu comme ça
fini c'est une commande d'un grand d'un
restaurant plutôt qui a été fait et ses
coussins ont été faits de
Madras de Jean en page rock c'est ce
qu'on appelle le pare-choc c'est
plusieurs tissus mélangés en tout
l'atelier accueille en plus de trois
permanents 16 salariés en insertion en
provenant essentiellement de la zone
nord de l'île
du quotient avec la toile de jute et il
y a eu la doublure avec quel que soit
avec le tissu mais qui se rapproche un
petit peu de la couleur de la toile de
jute
que je suis embauché
le travail manuel qui permet de se
ressourcer de laisser libre cours à son
imagination à sa force créatrice
l'occasion aussi de mûrir d'autres
projets comme celui de Sofia déjà bien
avancé
j'ai effectivement un projet de création
d'entreprise dans la revalorisation de
textiles plus précisément pour les
petits enfants et enfants de moins de 4
ans nous avons nous tendance en tant que
parents de vouloir beaucoup leur donner
beaucoup leur offrir accumulées et
certaines fois ils n'en ont même pas
l'utilité donc aujourd'hui ce serait
très prendre tout ce tissu qui serait
inutilisé ce qui est dans notre jargon
un déchet pour pouvoir en refaire de
nouvelles choses pour pour ces jeunes
enfants récupérer réparer revendre être
une alternative au plastique par exemple
pour les sacs autre champ à creuser
l'ameublement et la décoration et pour
les particuliers et pour les entreprises
la preuve en tout cas que l'idée de
recycler d'en faire tout un secteur
d'activité est devenu une réalité au
prêcheur